mit erhobenen händen rannten die schüler
am mittwoch über das gelände einer
highschool in parkland im us bundesstaat
florida
zuvor hatte hier ein 19 jähriger
ehemaliger schüler um sich geschossen
und mindestens 17 menschen getötet
die schüsse aus einem sturmgewehr fielen
kurz vor schulschluss und lösten panik
unter hunderten von schülern aus die
meisten opfer wurden im schulgebäude
erschossen es handelt sich sowohl um
schüler als auch mal wachsen
der 19-jährige täter ließ sich nach
behördenangaben widerstandslos
festnehmen
er sei erst vor kurzem aus
disziplinarischen gründen der schule
verwiesen worden sagte cherry
er ist in haft wir haben damit begonnen
uns die webseiten die er besucht hat und
seine aktivitäten in sozialen netzwerken
anzusehen einige dinge dort sind sehr
verstörend eltern durften ihre kinder
inzwischen von der schule abholen viele
stehen unter schock
ich war im ersten stock des gebäudes und
erst über den gang gelaufen er hatten
die klassenräume geschossen auch durch
meine tür
er war im dritten stock erkannte sich in
der schule aus er wusste wo die leute
waren aber vorbereitet
beschreibungen der schüler zufolge soll
der schütze ein einzelgänger mit faible
für schusswaffen und messer seien unter
einer gasmaske geschützt habe er auch
bomben gezündet
us präsident donald trump sprach den
angehörigen der opfer seine anteilnahme
aus kein kind lehrer oder überhaupt
jemand sollte sich jemals in einer
amerikanischen schule gefährdet fühlen
schrieb er auf twitter